[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
good Monday morning
this is the Tony Michaels for the Tony
Michaels podcast your home
[Music]
foreign
steppers holy
actual [__] Greg Abbott you bigot
oh boy
we have shooting victims in Texas five
including a child
from a neighbor who wouldn't stop
shooting their rifle their weapon of war
in the middle of the night
couldn't get their baby to sleep
so upset that he goes over and kills
five people it's apparently still on the
Run
and the governor of Texas decides that
he's going to disparage the victims
what in the [__] does their immigration
status have to be with being gunned down
by a neighbor
this is the exact kind of culture this
is the exact thing Greg Abbott that
caused
this to happen
when you dehumanize people
when you absolutely strip away their
Humanity
no no wonder it's so easy
for people where anyone and everyone can
get a gun to take people's lives in Mass
rather it be at a elementary school
a grocery store a church a bank
a parade route wherever in this country
folks I've been saying this for a long
time and I I honestly I could be just
yelling and screaming
at the top of my lungs
but I want to send a message to the two
a Bros out there because I'm talking to
you I'm not really talking to my
audience who are level-headed they they
understand exactly
the prom what the problem is it's the
guns they get it it's not it's not
[__] rocket science we understand
what's going on
the biggest difference between this time
in our history and the time in the 1990s
when we had a ban on assault weapons
and reasonable gun safety in this
country
is the gun it's the difference we didn't
have mental health care back then
no one was no one was given free mental
health care in this country or access to
free mental health care in this country
that's not a thing
there was just as many per capita people
mentally ill then as there is now
we're humans it's a human condition
but it's the gun and I want to say
something to the two-way Bros so listen
up [__] listen up I know I know
there's a few of you here who come and
hate watch
and really honestly if you replay this
video
listen turn the [__] volume up
you better you better get to the
negotiating table fast I've been telling
you this for a long time you better come
to your senses and understand that this
country and its citizenry is not going
to put up with this [__] any longer just
like We're Not Gonna Let You put up with
taking away our [__] Liberty to
health care or parental consent We're
not gonna let you take away our Liberty
to be able to just be out in the open
without having to [__] Dodge
high-powered rifles
we have the right to the pursuit of
Liberty and happiness and life you
mother you [__]
foreign
table fast
quick and in a hurry I'm telling you
I'm telling you it's not going to take
more than one more generation
of this [__] for them to take away the
entire second amendment
I'm telling you you better [__]
listen up
if you want to have your guns if you
wanna the idea of gun ownership at all
you better do it fast
it's time it's time you [__]
stop [__] around and lying to
yourselves and lying to this country
we're going to a lot of we're going to
let a handful of families in this
country that make God knows how much
money manufacturing these weapons
we're gonna let them dictate what we can
and can't do I think you're wrong I
think you're dead wrong and if you if
you think that your ability
to lobby and pile money on these
politicians like Greg Abbott is going to
work in the long term you are a dumb
sumbitch
especially when Greg Abbott has to use
has to use his statement
to put out a reward to find this
[__] scumbag
who killed this family because he had
access to a weapon that he should not
have access to
he disparages them he dehumanizes the
victims you you piece of [__] human
garbage Greg Abbott
why do you think why do you think that
person was able to just kill this family
by the way if it sounds like there's
evidence that that's all [__] that
they weren't illegal immigrants
the woman that was killed the mother was
here legally
you you [__] bigot you bigot ass
[__]
it's the same stupid [__] they did in
Nashville when the shooter turned out to
be a trans person and oh my God
it's the gun
gummy it's the [__] gun
nowhere else in the world does this [__]
happen nowhere
nope doesn't happen not a thing there's
mental issues in other countries it
exists where humans we're [__] humans
almost every single human has some sort
of mental illness and if you're not
self-aware enough to know that everyone
has mental conditions at some point in
their life you you really you really
need to have your head checked it's the
same idea when you have a person who's
against red flag laws you're the person
that needs to be red flagged
you're the person that needs to be red
flagged
that's right I said it hey hey 2A Bros
they're in the chat
you aren't speaking up this morning you
must uh smell what I'm stepping in
if you're against red flag laws which
doesn't red flag laws like bare minimum
doesn't go near far enough honestly I
think again I've said this on the show
here recently we should move the goal
posts to come and get your [__] guns
every last one of them March into your
house break down your door and take the
[__] from you and melt those
[__] down
[__] you
it's enough of this [__] stupid
garbage it's enough of this dumb
narrative it's enough of the stupid
[__] white gun culture I don't care
what color their [__] skin was it's
white gun culture
that's what it is
and if you don't believe me I'm gonna
read you the [__] statement from Greg
Abbott
he has to put he has to put their
[__] skin color
where they're from their Heritage their
[__] ancestry their race he has to
dump it into the message where he's
trying to apprehend this this criminal
ass [__] who should have never
owned a gun and the only reason why he
does is because of Greg Abbott
I said I wouldn't yell but I can't
[__] help it I can't help it it
pisses me the [__] off
that we have to sit here and [__]
pretend that the thing that's wrong is
it wrong
foreign
enough of it
and I'm telling you I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] what you 2A Bros
think or what what unin uninfringible
rat and god-given rat and second
amendment blah blah blah yakety smackity
I don't give a [__] you're not [__]
paying attention
you're not paying attention
even even people
who want to own guns are sick and tired
of the [__] they're sick and [__]
tired of it
they're tired of it
and they're gonna come get your [__] if
you don't move to the table now
I'm calling on you
to take a level head
to move to the table to negotiate to
stop this [__] nonsense
because the only reason why we're still
doing this is because the gun lobby
pretends that you're somehow the
majority and you're not you're [__]
not the majority you're not you are the
minority ideology on guns in this
country and someone questioned me in the
chat if it was white gun culture wow you
goddamn right wow that's what it is
[__]
it's the guns it's the guns it's the
[__] guns
and the justification of it is white gun
culture
[__] you you can do that oh you can
cancel me good go for it
go for it blast it on the internet that
I said it was white gun culture [__] you
that's what it is
what this wasn't the [__] this wasn't
the culture
when I was a kid around guns and I'm
white and I lived in rural Missouri
we didn't we didn't own guns to protect
ourselves from our enemies and those
brown people coming over the Border
that's not what we did or or oh we're
gonna a tyrannical government we didn't
have [__] deer rifles and shotguns to
to fend off the military
we kept our [__] doors unlocked the
cars were in the driveway with the
[__] keys in them
what were we protecting
you can take your stupid [__]
Arguments for guns and stick them
straight up your [__] ass
this country is not going to put up with
this much longer it's just not
kids being shot on front porches because
they rang the wrong doorbell opening the
wrong car door are you [__] [__] me
pulling in the wrong driveway honking
your horn at someone in traffic
well well [__] you
I'm sick of the [__]
I'm sick of the stories I'm sick of
hearing about it
and the other thing I'm [__] sick of
is people voting for these stupid ass
[__] bigots like Greg Abbott that's
right if you voted for Greg Abbott if
you're listening to me and you live in
Texas and you even thought about voting
for that [__] you are a bigot
and you are a piece of human garbage
injecting these People's race into it
and their legal status as if that
[__] matters a family was gunned down
in their home don't you have any any
[__] compassion at all you've you
piece of trash
and of course the media is like oh oh my
God I don't give a [__] Greg Abbott you
are a piece of [__] racist trash
it's time to get tough with these
[__] there's Nazis in Ohio
Nazis with flags running around I'm
gonna show you some [__] videos of
Nazis this morning
neo-nazis running around in costume
protesting costume shows I'm not
[__] you
this morning Donald Trump's attorney
doesn't file a motion he writes a
strongly worded letter and oh boy does
it have Donald Trump's sour grapes all
over it and it's denied denied [__] you
[__] you with your mistrial you can go
to hell
this country is sick of this [__] we're
sick of your [__] dumbass fascism
we're sick of your dumb ass stupid
[__] backwards thinking we're sick of
it we're tired of your dumb stupid
[__]
and I'm telling you it's not going to go
well in 2024 for republicans
and boy are they trying everything they
can trying everything they can
to try to get Donald Trump elected
including
including this No Label [__] which is
laughable
it's laughable right I mean you know
everyone's acting like this is a real
threat and the Democrats should be
scared of the No Labels people listen
folks all we got to do is mock the [__]
out of them
you think they're what candidate are
they gonna get the best candidate that
Republicans have to go against Donald
Trump right now isn't even Ron DeSantis
it's this Vivek clown
doesn't even know Contemporary American
history
you're the one in the fight you're the
jury here
you're the jury
speaking to trials you're the jury
it's what it is
but I can't I can't stress enough again
I'm talking to you [__] gun nuts out
there
who think that this country can't do
something about your Second Amendment
right to own
Whenever Wherever and however you want
you won't bull
[__] we can't and I'm telling you we're
going to
we want the Liberty to be able to get
out and do what we want without having
to dodge
High Velocity rounds of ammunition
coming from weapons of war
it's enough of this garbage
it is absolutely 100 enough of this we
have we have the ability we should have
the ability to send our teenage children
to go pick up their their their twin
brothers and not be terrified that they
go on the wrong porch and get [__]
shot
on the front porch that we don't have to
worry about our children open up our
wrong Corridor mistakenly getting shot
being in a class an elementary school
where they're learning math and
arithmetic like you run around saying we
just want our kids to learn math and
arithmetic reading social studies
we don't want them to have sex education
we don't want them in the classroom
learning arithmetic getting mowed down
and tearing apart by weapons of war
because why because you got a hard on
for guns because you're a fascist I
don't think so enough of that [__]
we're on to you
the majority ideology
is on to you
and I'm not I'm not just I'm not saying
Republican Democrat anymore folks
I'm not I'm not just saying Republicans
and Democrats anymore
it's the majority ideology and the
minority ideology
almost every single [__] issue every
[__] one of them
gains 60 70 percent of support in this
country and it's enough of the nonsense
it's enough of it we don't have to
[__] negotiate with them anymore we
don't we don't have to even act like
they're [__] ideology and their ideas
are even [__] relevant we just don't
we don't have to do that anymore
because anyone with common sense is now
on the left
it's ridiculous really honestly us on
the left can't even can't even have
[__] proper [__] debates
but it's true [__] them [__] them
[__] them
we don't have to they're with the Nazis
they're with the Nazis the Nazis are
with them they share the same ideology
as the Nazis the neon I'm going to show
you a video of it
I'm gonna show you a video I'm not not
just of the Nazis protesting the guy
who's yelling and screaming in the video
I'm gonna show you a [__] video of
his opinion of women's health care and
women's right to Health Care choices
and you're gonna have to try to [__]
convince me that this isn't every
[__] person who has an R next
to their name are votes for an r in this
country votes for a republican a fascist
it's enough of the compromise Kevin
McCarthy you can take your budget cuts
of child care and veterans benefits and
stick it up your [__] ass [__] you
kill the economy do it [__] do it do it
that's what the president and Chuck
Schumer should say to Kevin McCarthy do
it [__] do it
dare you
it's enough of this [__] enough of
it not for this soft-handed [__] [__]
that [__]
we're coming down to the nitty-gritty
here we're gonna have to get [__]
tough
and we're gonna have to stand and fight
for every single pro-democracy person in
every single pro-democracy candidate
that there is every [__] last one of
them
so turn the volume up get ready
because the election cycle is here
and it's time
it's time that we engage not yesterday
not last week not next week not next
month not when we get into next year now
is the time right now
right now is the time to engage in our
democracy
the Nazis are out in full force folks
and I'm not just talking about the ones
carrying the swastika Flags
it's not just them they're [__]
everywhere and let me tell you it's
going to be a hell of a fight
it's gonna be a hell of a fight and
we're gonna have to get them to fight
each other and boy are they doing it
we just have to poke the stick out of
them a little bit
a little bit here a little bit there
but it's time
it's time enough of this soft-handed oh
a Kumbaya [__]
we wanna we wanna hold hands
we want a compromise [__] you
compromise on what
compromise on what Greg Abbott
you dehumanizing people who are [__]
murdered
what do you what do you think caused
them to get murdered you think that
person you think that person is just
like you know I have the right to kill
this person I have the right to kill
this family because they're bitching
about the noise of my gun no he didn't
see them as humans
and ripped him apart with a high-powered
rifle
[__] that [__] we don't have to
compromise with Greg Abbott we don't
have to compromise with Kevin McCarthy
we'd have to compromise with Trump and
his allies [__] that [__]
[__] him
do it kill the economy do it [__] I
dare you Kevin McCarthy I [__] dare
you
keep coming after keep coming after the
lgbtq community keep holding your
[__] hands over your eyes and putting
your fingers in your ears over gun
safety
keep trying to take away women's right
to health care in these states keep
going do it [__] do it
you don't you don't you don't think
you've awoken us a [__] sleeping
giant what do you think woke means [__]
huh
it's time
it's it's time now is the time
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
they don't get it now they'll understand
soon went fast and in a hurry they'll
understand what's going to happen to
their ideology and their desires
to sexualized guns in this country
that's right they're amosexuals
ammo sexuals
okay well I want to report a little bit
on this uh e Gene Carroll trial
apparently
uh Donald Trump
is really upset that he can't he can't
he can't the fame
Eugene Carroll during the trial or he's
being super defamation you
of course the judge is having none of
this uh Taco penis you know and Joe Taco
penis you know his attorney and then his
name Taco penis do I got that right I
think I'm saying that right I don't know
maybe I'm sitting around uh he writes a
strongly worded letter
to the judge
why didn't you file a motion
I mean I'm no I'm not a [__] attorney
I'm not an attorney
far from it right I'm frankly I've been
on the the other side of the legal
system but yeah listen
I I I would imagine that your best
opportunity to get a mistrial is to I
don't know final emotion in court not
just send a strongly worded letter maybe
I I don't know
maybe I'm off my rocker again I'm not an
attorney so what the [__] do I know
um but it was denied this morning and
let's see it's about um
I don't know
20 minutes ago something like that
they denied it
denied [__]
of course everyone this morning who if
you read this if you read the letter you
would know yeah
laughs
yeah it's it's gonna it's not gonna go
well for you because it's just not
um it looks like yeah it was about an
hour ago I guess or so
I don't know I lose track of time when
I'm putting the um the show up and
because I'm trying to keep up with some
of the news that's breaking
uh judge Kaplan is the judge who um is
the presiding judge over the E Gene
Carroll rape case denied the motion for
mistrial uh from Trump's attorney Joe
Taco penis
again I think that's his name
his attorney his attorney
um now
that the allegations were in the letter
Trump's attorney Taco penis alleges that
the judge's bias
listen
Carol is the defendant and
in the law
especially during a defamation trial you
can't go on to continue to defame the
person who is suing you I mean you can
you can do that just like you can say
stupid [__] out loud right you have the
First Amendment right say stupid [__]
out loud
but you're not free from consequence
you're just you're just not now
some people have surmised that this is
an effort in the appeals uh part of the
process here because it's looking more
and more like Trump's case is crashing
and E Gene Carroll is going to win this
now she'll have to chase him around for
the rest of his [__] life which
hopefully isn't that long
sorry one of my what what do you want
from me I don't know I maybe I'm praying
thoughts and prayers for the
cheeseburger later on this afternoon I
don't know I mean listen as much as I
want this [__] to destroy the
Republican Party nothing would please me
more than a Big Mac to get Lodge I'm
just saying it's an accident it could
happen he's old he's feeble have you
seen how fat and sloppy he is he can
barely make his way around the golf
course it looks like he's he's he's
huffing
bags of oxygen when he's walking around
shaking hands at weddings at Mar-A-Lago
while he's crashing them what do you
want from me what do you want from me
health problems or health problems what
are you gonna do dude's old he's fat he
eats too much and he eats trash whatever
but he gets to disparage into Fame
Eugene Carroll all all he wants but it's
not going to help his case and honestly
every time he does it it's just more
evidence
of the defamation that was that was
dumped on E Gene Carroll here
and it doesn't bode well for his case
because this isn't a case where the
rather e Gene Carroll has to prove
that she was raped by Donald Trump
that's what everyone's missing the proof
just has to be the bar has to be that he
defamed her after the fact
so
[Music]
more rate stepping
I'll let them meet rake I got great news
for you we are so close and if you're on
patreon you've seen the um you've seen
the initial design here it's not a
colored design yet it's just a black and
white uh rough draft of the let them eat
rake merch that is coming it is [__]
coming in hot I'm hoping I'll have the
um at least at least the first draft of
the final design today sometime maybe
tomorrow we'll have the merch released
or Wednesday we'll have the merch
released in the store now we just want
to get it correct it's really cool so
far we're hoping that it's gonna be um
I'm hoping that it's going to be a big
hit
um because we're putting a lot of effort
in the artist is putting a lot of effort
into
um this this uh
into this design so
um The Latte meat rake design is coming
it is coming coming coming fast
um so I'm excited and if again if you're
on patreon you can see the first draft
of the design just go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels sign up to be on patreon
you'll be able to see the design
otherwise you have to wait but it's not
going to be too long I promise you'll
you'll see it very very very very soon
um but they just they can't stop
stepping on rakes they can't stop what
else was Rake stepping what else could
we now Gabe Sanchez is going to join us
here in just a minute
oh Josh Hawley stepped on a rake he's
running around telling people how to be
a man
come on really are you serious uh George
Santos is trending I don't know why I
have no idea
why is George Santos trending now we
haven't heard anything out of that
[__] line piece of [__] in a while
have we I haven't at least
he's apparently in a rerun right
um oh here's huge breaking news it looks
like Washington Post is reporting that
uh George Santos is in fact
uh part of a criminal probe into his
campaign finances
oh no oh no that's
it's gonna be horrible for him
oh
and it's horrible for his constituents
for him to why is he running
is is this the whole Trump thing where
I'm not giving up is this like a this
this look this is clearly this clearly
has to be George Santos has it in his
mind that he thinks
that he's he's some kind of trump
reincarnate right that he can win his
race because frankly it's kind of the
same thing if you want to know the truth
like it it's probably likely
that that he'll get primaried and and
he'll lose but I mean it it could be he
could be the Republican candidate
honestly I think what democrats should
do
um is change your registration because I
believe New York is not an Open Primary
and yet be registered uh in New York am
I right on that I'm I'm not a citizen of
New York I've never voted in New York so
I wouldn't know exactly without having
the research in front of me but I
believe New York is a closed primary if
someone out there who is in New York who
confirmed that but I believe it's a
close primary as opposed to an Open
Primary see here's the difference a
closed primary when you go into the
voting booth you have to pull the ticket
that you're registered for so if you're
registered
um
um IB says yes you are Tony I don't know
what that means yes live here it's true
yeah so so it is closed it is closed
Missouri is an Open Primary it's like
literally as long as I'm just registered
to vote and I don't register as a
Democrat I don't register as anything I
just registered to vote it's an open
open registry so I can actually go in
and I can pull whichever primary ticket
I want I can pull the Republican ticket
or I can pull the Democratic ticket but
in New York it is closed so
maybe maybe just maybe a lot of people
in his district
will I don't know change the
registration so they can make sure he's
the one who's on the ballot
I'm just saying these are all that's a
legal strategy folks it's a legal
strategy that you can you know
make sure the candidate that you want to
run is running
I mean you know you want to have a a
legitimate race against an incumbent
like George Santos and his Challenger so
why not make sure that George Santos is
the incumbent on ticket
you're saying that could be a strategy
to win that seat hmm
um
could be
let's see what else ow
it looks like he's been speaking
um
in front of the young Republicans
I'm getting Tongue Tied this morning
young Republicans in New York and
there's a video down on that maybe we'll
watch that we'll see what uh we'll see
what Gabe Sanchez says Gabe Sanchez um
has actually talked to George Santos
before like talk to him talk to him you
know let's see here
let's see
Chevron is trending JP Morgan is
trending
um they um they bought First Republic
Bank the FDIC decided this morning this
is the and this is the uh I believe the
second largest bank in this country's
history but it's the Third Bank
um since we've had some of these um
banks closed that the FDIC has reigned
in
um so and again there's no there's no at
this point there's no Market Panic no
one's no one in the stock market's
panicking and the reason why is because
the system the FDIC Insurance system and
the government system where they're
making sure these assets are safe and
the assets being the depositors assets
um are safe is it's working it's working
why I I you know because I was listening
this morning in in the media
um wants to try to [__] make this
into oh we're headed for recession and
this and that and oh my God this is a
bad thing and Americans this and
Americans are going to not pay attention
listen
listen to me when I tell you this what
is happening with the banks is what
should have happened in 2008.
I think about think about 2008 and what
happened
and and and we had to go bail these
[__] out after the fact after
it destroyed our economy
they're they're doing this in a foreman
fashion the way it is designed so we
don't have some [__] like that happen
again
and the one reason why folks is because
we have people who are [__] serious
about policy in the economy in charge
they're serious about it
they're not just [__] haphazardly
making policy
so yeah yeah did we bail out the second
largest bank
or the FDIC closure that we had the
second largest and this is the third
bank since this has started yes yes but
they're they're doing it the way it
should be done
yeah
hello think McFly think it's working the
Market's not crashing there's not Market
Panic people aren't hanging on to their
dollars like they were at 2008 I don't
know if you guys remember
I don't know how long you've been around
and 2018 likes you know lifetimes ago I
guess to some but I remember that
[__] I remember 2008 I was a
young adult with a young family then I
remember how [__] tough it was
and I remember all the [__] that
this country went through
because of the [__] in charge of
[__] at the time
and when we put the Democrats in power
soon after 2008 because of it in some
degree
they changed banking regulations they
moved to increase the FDIC
I don't know if you remember any of that
you remember any of that you [__]
knuckleheads
so yeah what they're doing is what they
should have done and it is working
and they're making sure to not
breed in comp incompetence in the market
they want competence in the markets they
want confidence in the economy
and it's working
just because just because there's not
some sort of dramatic story where the
country's falling apart
because level-headed people are in
charge doesn't mean that it's not
working
it doesn't mean that
so you can try to stoke Panic all you
want you can try to stoke lies all you
want
you can try to say that the economy is
not stable
but clearly this morning the the stock
market and the market believes it
because it's gone up can you believe
that Gabe Sanchez you would think on
some of these Twitter accounts that that
entire economy is going to crash this
morning on on Morning Joe because I
listened to it on Mondays oh my God I'm
gonna give you another we're gonna be a
recession
I don't know
that's the second largest this third
bank when there's three of them oh it's
a trend there's three yeah there's a
trend yes and that's what the FDIC
insurance is for that's what that's what
they're doing they're making what system
is in place work for the American people
not for [__] Banks this isn't this
isn't good for for First Republic Bank
this is horrible for public Bank frankly
there is going to be no First Republic
Bank it's gonna be JP Morgan
and the reason why is because it sucks
to suck but the depositors are safe
that's the whole [__] point
of the fdiec system I don't know if
people know that you know the other
thing that this morning that has lost
none of these [__] because they
keep talking about they compare this
Bank crisis right uh back to 2008 they
keep comparing it yeah not comparable
because the system is actually doing
what it's supposed to do so we don't
have to half-ass bail them out after our
[__] entire economy collapses now
well yeah I mean that's assuming that
nobody I don't know uh repealed certain
regulations that were put in place after
2008 right wow wow wow don't act like
don't act like every every bad policy is
a republican boss is that what you're
saying but here's I'm just saying like
it's not a policy or rather lack thereof
oh yes because yeah we're gonna look in
turn a blind eye to it yeah like oh man
you guys keep doing what you're doing we
won't need to check those things as if
you know and here the other thing too is
like
to the degree of which that happened
obviously that it's been some time
before that but it was a bit different I
mean our economy Works in an ebb and
flow right that's we we can't ever get
too big and we can't ever go too low
like we are going to there's going to be
uh growth and there's going to be uh
um you know not growth that happens
right there's it's going to go stagnant
for a bit of time there's going to be
um like I said there's an ebb and flow
into which the economy rolls
um but we want to make sure that we have
certain protocols in place to make sure
that it doesn't get too big so that when
it does crash it's a huge crash or that
when it goes down into an ebb right or
or like a low Point does it get too low
on its own
so there's certain things in place
Republicans like ah [__] him you know
the [__] lazy Fair invisible hand a
little let the market decide on its own
and it's like no we can't do that
because there are certain actors who are
Bad actors and they're going to take
advantage of the system and they're
going to [__] things up and we've now
seen that well you know this morning all
the right Wingers and a lot of the the
what what they claim to be free market
capitalists they're like they're like
whoa whoa whoa there is no you there's
no freedom of choice in your bank when
JP Morgan's gonna buy you the reason why
JP Morgan the government is turning to
JP Morgan because they have a shitload
of capital I don't know if I don't know
if you they got a [__] they got a
mountain of [__] money and they can
handle it and actually honestly this
morning it's apparently JP Morgan is
announcing they're going to turn profit
on this they're going to turn profit and
everyone's like well I don't want to be
a JP Morgan customer I wanted to be a
first Republican Bank customer
then take your deposits and go somewhere
else the good news is the good news is
the government made sure your deposit is
there to take somewhere else you [__]
idiot what I just don't understand and
again I I get the markets and I get the
investor side of it because they're
they're really upset about about the
selling and buying of their well they're
also probably I mean like here's the
other thing too like obviously the FDIC
insures up to 250 000 right and most
normal people yourself myself other
people watching probably don't have more
than that
you don't have 250 that over 250 000 in
one account come on I have that I have
them split up dude
okay 250 000
249 000 and one 249.
savings you got a chance
credit union banks nice large Banks got
medium-sized Banks I got couch cushions
I got mattresses
and the mattresses all FDIC injured as
well
the couch I bought them from a place
called FDIC insurance so I just figured
they were insured I don't know the most
that I've seen is that on the tag it's
like if you remove this and it's you
know by penalty of law so I don't know
maybe those things are connected not
really sure but you know you have all
these Republicans just like normal
average people right who do not have all
of that or that amount of money in a
bank account and they'll go no the
government is like did you have that
much did you have more than that much
money did you have more than money
because if so then you probably either
one should have split it invested it put
it somewhere else and not put it all in
one in place but also you have to
understand that all of those people are
complaining
are nowhere near the people who are the
ones who took advantage of the situation
right who were you know working with
teal and wanted a short Silicon Valley
Bank or or try to uh you know obviously
short the market and take advantage and
and then still get like double dip take
the money out then it's a whole if you
think if you think for a second that it
isn't big investors that made a bundle
on this because here's what's happening
this morning here's he's really pissed
off it's the investors because here's
the facts
84 First Republic branches are now JP
Morgan they're safe all all the First
Republic deposits and plus their
mortgage and the and the loans that they
hold have been assumed by JP Morgan
they're safe your money's safe it's
insured that's the whole point of the
FDIC what is what is not like this
morning is that is that first Republic
bank's Share value is nothing it's zero
right Natsu's really pissed but hey man
that's what investing is [__]
that's what it is and when you go into
the bank and it has the sign that says
your money is insured the government us
we the government should make sure that
we [__] hold to our promise right
that when you add the depositors money
in that bank that it's [__] safe what
the investors wanted want to do [__]
them it's almost like you know FDIC was
created
to help protect people after something
might have happened years years ago
right what could have happened what
could have happened almost a hundred
years ago we made sure to put an an
insurance a federal insurance that we
backed as a as a government in place to
protect the economy and people's money
what could it possibly have been I don't
know it's almost like oh man it's really
it's kind of depressing to think about
um depressing depressing that sounds
familiar oh oh the Great Depression
right it's almost like they wanted to
avoid a run on the banks right to make
sure hey don't have to worry Don't Panic
if you come here your money will be
protected right and so it's it's that
idea that and the other thing too is
like the reason that the government is
so trusting of JPMorgan Chase is because
I don't know maybe like in 2008
something happened and they were like
hey we want to partner with you guys to
make sure that all of the [__] Banks
uh uh don't crash and and Burn Right
like we have to make sure that you know
too big to fail is the is the situation
which we had but it's almost like they
had a relationship and still have a
relationship with JPMorgan Chase and say
hey look these are our
it's like when you when you go somewhere
and they're like hey I you know where
would you recommend I go eat right if
you go to like an Airbnb or or a hotel
they'll give you like you know places
that they partner with or places they
highly recommend to like send uh a
business over there it's the same way
here where the government's like oh you
know what
we have a good tracker with JPMorgan
Chase we trust them they pay they pay
the the the loans back with interest we
you know they're they're protected we've
looked at their Capital we know they
have money it's not going to crumble and
crash and and cause the whole system to
collapse right and so that's that's
another thing that people need to
to understand is like that's a reason
why the government went with JPMorgan
Chase is because
they you know in the last 15 years or so
they've proved themselves again
that they've been able to pay back and
some right
on the money that was was given to them
well the other the other thing too is um
with our government because it is us is
we have the ability to put serious
people in place that make sure to hold
JP Morgan in check and if JP Morgan
isn't on check on on these deposits and
these branches and these mortgages that
they're buying then we can force them to
sell them that is the whole [__]
point here is is that this morning the
markets and companies aren't freaking
the [__] out I mean the people who are
invested in First Republic Bank are a
little pissed off this morning but hey
go cry and whine the management of that
bank I don't know what the [__] to tell
you you took bag bets I don't want I
don't know what else to do with you
right look you're you're talking about
legalized gambling and they took bad
bets and they [__] their depositors
but us as a country doesn't do that
anymore we've done it once in 1929 where
we didn't have insurance we did it once
again in 2008 when we did have FDIC
Insurance do you know the reason why
it's 250 000 now no why don't you tell
us in 2008 it wasn't
it wasn't to him it was like what a
hundred right it was a hundred yeah yeah
it was 50 and 100. yeah yeah but now
it's 250. yeah and there's a reason for
it is I don't know to make sure that
confidence stays in the market when
something like this happens like they
literally rate because back then
obviously a lot of people were scared
right especially for that 12 months um
you know leading up to where we started
to be on an upward Trend again it was
about 12 18 months before we could get
to an upward Trend again in this country
I mean we know what happened it was
different than this time because the
economy was much different than this
time completely different
completely different marks on the
economy it's just not the same but the
point is is that they did it then so
that way in the future when it happened
again and Banks there was a couple banks
that made bad bets in the economy they
weren't properly managed then hey
we got you covered don't freak the [__]
out because I don't know if you remember
when bear Stearns and Lehman Brothers
holy [__] I mean everyone woke up like
what the [__] the market tanked
everyone's running I do want her hair on
fire that's funny that you you mentioned
that because I was looking back I'm
doing a what was that on Joe Biden and
uh Roy Wood Jr at the the White House
correspondent good we're gonna watch a
few of those clips today and I went back
because I was like oh you know there's
some clips I want to bring up like
Michelle wolf right and uh Seth Meyers
and Obama and just [__] ragging on
Donald Trump and bragging on Sarah
Huckabee Sanders but there's a joke that
Michelle wolf has in her
her bit when she's there and she goes
you know I used to work uh at a tech
company I used to work on Wall Street
like I used to work at um I think she
said Lehman Brothers are bears I think
she did work at Lehman Brothers yeah
yeah and she goes uh
and she was like basically like that's
the LA like uh believe me like I've been
[__] before you know like it happened
there on Wall Street like that was the
that was the last time that uh men went
down on me without my consent right like
there's a whole thing and it was like
none of the Republicans in there were
laughing at all like a lot of people who
were able to take the joke Republicans
laugh I know yeah I know I know they're
not one to uh to take it but they love
to Dish it and when I say dish it I mean
like Bully and bigot and be racist and
you know kind of like uh with Nazi Flags
yeah yeah yeah
um
First Amendment you guys got to be able
to say what you want but uh however if
you say those things back to me that's
me me that makes boo-boo I'm hurt my
names don't call me names exactly we
need a safe space as Marjorie Taylor
green says speaking of that you know
what Nazis oh yeah with a capital N a
capital in yeah so
I showed this yesterday on the patreon
Sunday rant okay
um and and this guy this guy shows up
again
um is down his face is it like a
lightning bolt I no that's like a I
don't know what the hell that is to be
quite honest because like when when
people get like uh when they have like
an electrical burn mark that happens
like well it I mean it looks like a
branch like it like right you'll get
like yeah so when I see that on the top
side of the space it looks I mean it's
probably not it's probably something
racist who knows
um I'm sure it is but it kind of at
first glance it reminded me of like a
electrical like burn mark that like goes
through right and shows itself on your
body now this guy's name is
um I think his name is Chris racist
O'Connor um Paul Paul Haas is AKA his
nickname is hammer
[Music]
oh man you couldn't you couldn't project
any more [__] little dick energy than
a nickname like Hammer they call me here
my name is Hammer I got the hammer [__]
you're the nail
um but there is what what I didn't oh
speaking of wish I just learned uh this
is for everyone else out there I didn't
know if maybe you knew this
so you know when you have a hammer right
you got the you got the Flathead and you
got the hook end I I've used a hammer
for you right or right I've never I've
never used the hammer this way until I
saw a video of course I'm [__] Tick
Tock where you learn everything these
days
you use the curved end that you'll
typically like uh nail from to hold it
the initial the initial hit in that I
never in one way that is one I've never
I was some some framing hammers have a
magnet on the head and a notch
um and some some people are good enough
they can actually hold the nails yeah I
mean I hold until I hit it I'm not going
you know but I saw it and I was like
what the are you serious yeah
use a nail gun like when they're framing
okay stuff all right science and [__]
well you know this is modern times sort
of
um so let me uh let me let me show you
this video this is in Columbus Ohio
um it's gonna look very similar to a
video we showed a couple months ago on
its own Columbus Ohio is definitely so I
had a buddy a little side note I had a
buddy who moved from Chicago to Columbus
and we were driving through and this is
like the first time this is the yeah
yeah I know honestly Patrick Patrick on
YouTube says oh boy carpentry tips by
Gabe that could be a new segment I just
want to say I can I beg you Jesus Christ
didn't even know that tip okay I just
want to say that okay suck it Jesus yeah
suck it okay if I have to be you know 30
and just realize how the [__] used
not just use the end to retract a nail
from the wall but also use oh you're a
carpenter oh you're a carpenter yeah
water into wine I'm [__] Jesus Christ
oh God damn anyways your friend in
Columbus sorry
he moved he moved to Columbus and
um
as we were driving in because he was it
was me and my buddy that were coming in
to visit him and they came into Chicago
and they did a road trip to go pick up
some remaining stuff from the old house
and we were driving into Ohio and they
were like hey because this first time
I'd really been in Ohio previous times I
just flown into visit uh family and
they're like hey just so you know you're
gonna see some stuff as we come from the
outside in
to Columbus like from the outside yeah
yeah stuff like you might see I don't
know uh he's like a burning cross
somewhere or you might see like you know
random racist type of
decorations we'll say right
um and we saw we saw some stuff uh not
any like burning Cross or anything but
they were like the last time we came
through here they were there there was
some stuff that was off like off the
highway that we saw it was like you know
whatever anyway point being
the history of Ohio and it being racist
is definitely like ingrained in it so to
hear that there were Nazis in Columbus
Ohio not surprising at all
I did not see that coming but I also did
not not see that coming right and so you
know I wouldn't be surprised if they you
know like Children of the Corn they
[__] came out of the crops because
they were like oh you know what that is
we got to go after those trans gay
people you know got to go over those
minorities you know the funniest part
about this is I'm gonna I'm gonna show
you this clip yeah and I want to warn
the audience it does have she wants to
give lags on it there is Nazis but it
actually to me it's kind of hilarious
and here's why is because it's a bunch
of [__] grown ass men in costumes
right chanting and kind of singing in
concert
to protest
a costume show it's really [__] kind
of weird that of course they're trying
to not only their faces with masks but
they got gloves on them did you see the
ones in Boston this weekend no I didn't
see well I saw some clips of Patriots
Yeah pull up pull that up pull those
Nazis up too but here's here's the Nazis
in Ohio
and you're gonna see uh the little big
camera guy here
but you notice they're all hiding their
faces their eyes their hands
[Music]
here
here's the guy here's hammer
I think Hammer has a lot of uh Hitler
energy here doesn't he with the uh now I
want I want to point this out the guy
looks like he's a goddamn valet or he's
working he's a host at a [__] right
editoring event at a big bigotry Buffet
but here's here's the thing if you look
down here on this Freeze Frame okay
dude dude didn't even wear black socks
man he wore white socks are you [__]
kidding me here we're gonna wear the
costume wearing the whole costume damn
man you [__] ruined it you totally
[__] ruined it Hammer I was gonna
believe that you were some sort of
organized [__] group of bigots and
Nazis I was gonna give a little bit of
credit here Jesus Christ but you're
wearing white socks man everyone knows
every even dumb [__] that don't know
fashion no you don't wear black pants
black shoes you know what I think in
white socks man you know what I think it
is the white power thing no no no no no
no what happened was so you know when
you ride a bike right and you want to
make sure that you don't get your pants
stuck into the chain so you roll your
socks over the pants that's what I think
happened he wrote it he wrote his little
bicycle black tube socks no no no no no
no he wrote dress socks dress socks no
okay dress shot dress socks you really
think I mean look well look it looks
like he's got loafers these are [__]
white tube socks that he bought from
right Sam's Club all right it's Sam's
Club you think this guy's got enough
[__] miracle to go get some details
at Sam's Club maybe a a Dollar General
could be yeah sure whatever I don't know
he's probably buying his [__] used I
think that's what happened I think
honestly he had his he had his sock that
was covering his pants so he didn't
catch it in the in the bike chain
because he was like okay I'm riding from
my mom's house and he's got to ride all
the way back to his mom's house for
dinner you know hey oh well listen poor
Hammer here uh with his White Sox let's
let's see if he has anything really
substantive to say here
[Applause]
I was looking at the tattoo which is
I'm sure it's some [__] dumb symbol
that means something [__] racist I'm
not saying that a person with a face
tattoo is automatically an idiot but you
do have to assume at first glance if you
have tatted your face and shaved your
head and dressed like this yeah there's
probably a good chance that you're a
dumb [__] I'm just gonna say that yeah
if you dress like this shaver and have a
tattoo on the side of your face like
that you might make that assumption yeah
I mean
the other thing that you could do is
listen to [__] he says not just yelling
and screaming in front of a costume show
where he's dressed up in a costume to
protest said costume show but maybe the
[__] he says on so where does he make
his money and it's still true the people
I well I mean I'm sure I'm sure there's
a lot of uh right now I gotta look this
guy up right right yeah Nazi Hammer hear
it here here he is on a um
here he is
on a podcast somewhere I think or
something any listen he's talking about
his view of women's rights and
you could probably guess where he stands
on women's rights and it's it's exactly
what you think it is like it's like
you're like oh he's a republican he
should he should be he should be in the
Tennessee state legislator maybe the
Florida state legislator with an R next
to his name
because it really does have this um
stench of conservatism let's religious
conservatism white Christian nationalism
if you want to know the honest truth
let's listen to what Hammer says about
women's health care and their right to
health care and it's still true the
people will take War Brides In the End
of days and it's it's just gonna happen
okay what what the the War Brides so
this guy here's his name Gabe Chris uh
Paul Haas I think it's how you said got
it got it AKA Hammer
um and his plans to build a tiny house
now from the other [__] one yes yeah
where he's yelling and screaming he's
standing yeah same [__] same
[__] wow okay same [__]
um and he's apparently wanting to build
some sort of tiny house compound
um I guess so he can live with his War
Brides I don't I'm not really sure what
how old are these warbreads I don't know
I don't think he goes into that but
listen to what he thinks about War
Brides and just women in general be if
they may become War Brides this is
something else okay and for you know
honestly I don't find that liberal white
women
have the right to decide about how their
reproductive system is going to be used
oh really
really says that
liability to
choose how they're reading I might need
to go get an Excedrin because this guy's
giving me a [__] headache right now
if you were wondering if he's a Nazi or
just pretending to be a Nazi he's
definitely definitely a Nazi now most
people say Tony why are you showing this
folks what I'm about to show you is
basically mainstream Republican policy
right now in state legislators you
stupid [__] Rhonda santis signed a bill
that basically puts this guy's ideology
into law in Florida okay Most states are
moving Republican states and Republican
legislators are moving to move to move
state law and state policy to this guy's
policies position that the [__] face
Branch tattoo guy who's yelling and
screaming in a costume protesting with
swastikas costume shows here's more take
a look
if the world crumbles because of them
and I'm standing by that I I do find
them to be uh enemies to us and if they
leave themselves on the position of
being an enemy they should be treated as
such and one of them so so they're an
enemy to us now I can only I can only
imagine who he considers to be us but my
guess is it's him and the 12 other dudes
what yeah yeah uh does he have a [__]
a Great Britain flag behind him that yes
yes it's weird I don't know I I don't
know what what do you I mean you want me
to explain every single little
he might think it's the stars and bars
he might have it confused with the stars
and bars you know the Confederate flag
he might he might Hammer might be Dumber
you know I I don't know I mean I I mean
it's weird the idea like look man I mean
look I get that we have a lot of races
but holy [__] man we got a lot of
[__] dumb races out there
um
I just don't I mean maybe in someone in
the chat knows is that in fact it looks
like a [__] UK flag that's what it
looks like well look look it up see if
you can pull a picture of them see if we
can confirm that
um but again he may be dumb enough I
mean he sounds pretty [__] stupid to
me
he may be dumb enough to think it's the
stars and bars the Confederate flag it's
it's possible but let's keep listening
to his policy on Women's Health Care
specifically white liberal Women's
Health Care which is kind of weird but
yeah go ahead boom is losing the rights
and the uh control of how their
reproductive system is to be utilized
that is very scary for people to hear it
is very edgy and it is not popular but
at least he knows that it's not popular
okay okay sorry wait I think I found it
it's it's actually all right so there's
a thing that's called and I don't know
which one it is because there's so many
different versions of it but uh it's the
Imperial fascist League possibly oh wait
wait what did you say Imperial what I
said I thought you said fascist what
you're saying fascist with a hard F oh
okay good uh fascist uh but there's also
one there's oh my God it's like man
these people who make these flags are so
just uncreative
um wait wait wait you think this guy
this guy is a creative individual no no
there's another there's another one
called the Coalition of the willing to
power hold on let me let me look this up
so there's another flag that looks like
Great Britain flag but it's Gotta so the
other one had a it's like a a British
flag almost with
um and I don't want to bring it up on
the screen because [__] anyone can
search for it anyway it looks like Great
Britain what what do they need to type
into Google to find these I mean you
could look up UK flag Nazi okay okay so
go to Google Images UK flag Nazi yeah
yeah so there's another one that's
Imperial fascist League like I said and
there's another one which looks it's
like more of a school like a four by
three version which is the same symbol
with the swastika in the middle looks
like you know Great Britain flag but in
the top left corner it's uh the 50 stars
of our flag and so but when I look when
I look up this group called The
Coalition of the willing to power
which is a fascist group yeah yeah it
says it's a
it's a used Prof flag for okay so that
this is
okay this is from the movie all right
that's different I think it's from the
movie V for Vendetta
uh the flag that's behind him yeah hold
on let me yeah yeah no no no no no hold
on hold on okay I gotta make sure I
gotta make sure this is all real I see I
see I see well I'm gonna let me no yeah
it's British fascist so I don't know but
but the other one was used in the movie
V for Vendetta so but they're supposed
to be British fascists then this is the
Imperial fascist League was a British
fascist political movement founded in by
Arnold lease in 1929 after he broke away
from the British fascist it included
black shirted
paramilitary arm called the fascist
Legion modeled after the Italian fascist
the group espoused anti-Semitism and the
dominance of the airline race yeah you
don't say yeah it says they dissolved in
1939 but we know a lot of these guys I
mean dissolved really do you think this
guy's dissolved I mean his brain is
probably but I don't know who knows what
it is it could be the Brit this fascist
League flag it could be a Confederate
flag I mean honestly
every one of uh whichever one right
whichever it's Confederate whichever
it's fascist whatever it might be both
of them lasted mere years in actual
existence and these guys are still
Clinging On to a dead [__] Dream well
it's gonna die a horrible death here in
this country because really honestly
this guy is mainstream Republican at
this point listen listen to his
mainstream Republican real America First
Nazi ideas listen here I don't care
they're tearing uh they're tearing our
world down they're burning it all up and
they're anti-white opposition
and that's that's it they're anti-white
opposition right and I'm sorry but who's
Burning It Down who's tearing it up
it's almost like there's a group of
people that might uh I don't know
believe in
I don't know being racist anti-semitic
uh just straight up bigoted all around
they want to control women's bodies if
they don't get their way we've you know
like during the 2020 BLM uh protest
there was the guy that was in Minnesota
who burned who caused fires in many
places like the Minneapolis Police
Station as well as that AutoZone
boys
Nazis exactly like oh look it's all
these we saw these BLM people and it's
like wait but each each one of these
guys were white and they were [__]
Boogaloo and they're this person racist
and they were white supremacists
so anyway if anyone if you ever hear
anyone be like oh they cost two billion
dollars in damage maybe take a step back
and look at the people who actually
started the destruction who actually
burned these things down don't you find
it kind of funny that the people who
blame the lie on BLM on these people
burning these building down are the same
people who have the same views and
policies and ideology as Hammer does on
Women's Health Care isn't that kind of
funny crazy I wonder what that could be
I wonder if I don't know if that is
anything there's a there's a Venn
diagram and it's almost a complete
circle it's almost like Republicans are
are Nazis or something huh it's almost
like I've been saying that speaking of
Nazis here they are in Boston
um this is a different uh sect of Nazis
though
um this is the Patriot front they got I
have to I I have to say the Patriot
fronts uniforms I mean we're gonna be
objective here right Patriot fronts
uniforms are much more
preppy then the then the uh the Ohio
yeah I mean the Hammers yeah you know
yeah yeah they're very basic you can fly
you can find a blue shirt anywhere you
try to find a red jacket somewhere good
luck right it's almost like it's almost
like the difference between Target and
Walmart like like hammers Nazis he's
like look go to Walmart get you pair of
black boots black slacks white socks
don't forget the white socks because
white power you know what I'm talking
about and then get your red shirt and
we'll we'll we'll iron on a design on
the front like that's the Walmart
version that's Hammer's version right
yeah and then pager in fronts are like
Walmart who shops at Walmart we used to
have a Target okay it's not Target it's
not targeting
oh that's what it is
okay well I'm I'm just saying no funny
story I did when I I made a couple I
made a couple sketches that were uh
making fun of patriot front when they
were at the at the Lincoln Memorial and
also when they were
all right
you
it isn't Target it is Old Navy yeah yeah
but I will say this I did go to I did go
to Target to buy a blue shirt to finish
the costume that I had when I was
pretending to be the Patriot front so I
used it in both my U-Haul commercial
I went to Target and I bought a blue
shirt so I know where they get them oh
okay well
I'm saying I went to Target Tarjay
that's where I got it fair enough here
is um
here is uh Patriot front uh and it looks
like they're on an L or a train
um yeah yeah and I think it's like
they're they're messing do they call it
did they caught do they call their Metro
the L uh no no because it's not elevated
the only place is the only place they
have elevated trains are green line they
call it the line green line right yeah a
lot of places are more on ground level
you've got New York elevated train
Chicago elevated train those are the L
that you get I guess yeah okay well I'm
a Country Boy you know it's okay you
know you can't be like these Coastal
Elites you know yeah well I don't I
don't have we have subways where I'm
from should go get a sandwich there get
you a sandwich
Five Dollar Foot Longs okay let's see
what these five dollar footlongs have to
offer here in Boston on the green line
so check this out and he's laughing
hahaha
you're an idiot all of these guys right
need to come to Massachusetts to spread
their hate
they come to Massachusetts to spread
their hate because they have nothing
else to spread by hate
uh Gabe Sanchez I don't know everything
that he said there but this is exactly
how you would treat Nazi yeah he
basically said he called them scared
Nazis uh he called them you know pieces
of [__] yeah I mean it's pretty funny to
to one because when I I could not stop
laughing I was like oh look patreon and
I was not expecting right the voice
Spanish to come right out of the gate
and I was like this is [__] amazing I
mean just like boom he did not he did
not as dating not to quit he did not
stop it was it was it was pretty good
but yeah so I guess we did not see that
coming they did not see it yeah that's
true they did not the Nazis did not see
that coming but it's uh yeah I guess the
account if you go to the account uh yeah
there's another video here um but I
guess he was I guess he was following
damn it it's Rod Weber yeah um he's put
out a few videos well he had the video
with the guy who was yes they're crazy I
want to show part of that I want to show
and I want to show another video that
you released this morning Rod did some
great interviews that have kind of went
viral
um online and here's here's another
because there will be here's another
video um from that thread let's watch
this one everybody say hi to Rod Weber
say hi to Rod Weber
is he this look at this look at this
[__] is covering their faces this
[__]
to bring their face they cannot show
their face because they will be shame
publicly oh man they definitely don't
want to lose it it's true I mean all of
these guys do not want us to show their
face they're like oh uh I'm not gonna be
here on Monday guys I'm taking a little
R and R and by that I mean Marching In
My Little underwear face covering
bunch of [__] Nazis and again the
reason why I want to show you this stuff
the audience is um how much they it
feels like they're I I don't know
Republicans I don't know just Hammer
there with his his uh his policy on
Women's Healthcare it really does feel
like
that he votes identifies and he likes um
Republican politicians that's who it's
almost like if you were like hey who are
you going to vote for in 2024 he'd be
like Trump and Trump only you think
that's what he would say Trump for for
president Trump for VP and you're like
you can't existence like Trump Speaker
of the House hey hey
no wait wait wait wait wait so I was in
the Cary Lake Twitter space listen to
her I was all the same old wife
yesterday so so I I went into the
Twitter space to listen to that [__]
scumbag talk a little bit Yeah and of
course it's always the same online same
[__] different neighbor but I will say a
little bit of the breaking news because
someone asked Carrie Lake if that [__]
was gonna run and I said [__] that I
said it I said record it put it out May
1st 1 20 p.m eastern time Tony called
Carrie like a [__] she blocked me by the
way because I said she had sour grapes
anyways the point is this the little bit
of news that she made in this space I
thought the rest of it again was all the
same [__] different diaper
uh you know I I won when I lost and and
because I lost I'm gonna take this all
the way to the sister Services the
system Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court's gonna give me what I want get
the [__] out of here the Supreme Court's
gonna that National Supreme Court's
gonna overturn the the Arizona Arizona
state election get the [__] out of here
you are a bonehead anyways the news was
someone asked her if she's gonna run
with Trump as her as his VP oh and Kerry
Lake didn't say she wouldn't but what
she did say and I [__] started
laughing hysterically and she was like I
actually don't think Trump needs a
running mate he can run all by himself
I'm like that that is fantastic let's do
that please let's do that let let's make
sure Donald Trump does not pick a vice
presidential candidate and he isn't
going to pick a vice president until he
becomes president yeah let's do that
Trump is like I was so tired of carrying
Mike Pence on my back and mother that
I'm gonna do it by myself this time I'm
gonna run the White House just
unilaterally it's gonna be me and me
only but she literally said that [__]
that he was he's gonna run all by
himself she's also the same person was
like uh these people from the East Coast
these Elites showed up to my door whoa
whoa whoa whoa Elites from where the
East Coast what you mean like like
Manhattan
yeah Manhattan our Queens in other
places like Manhattan
am I getting a big huge tall building
that they own with like golden elevators
and [__] it's almost like there's a
place with the big D on the front
and the rest of the name is rump
because Coastal yeah right those Coastal
it's it's oh no it's probably different
it was probably yeah probably different
ones right of course right I mean it's
definitely not the the Florida Coastal
leads uh but I guess supposedly remember
when at CPAC she said
she said that uh some people some
mysterious people you know backed by big
money from the coast I'm sure she has
the evidence stored somewhere yeah yeah
she's like they showed up to my house
knocked on my door and told me we'll
offer you a large sum of money to not
run oh get the [__] out of here [__] no
one's offering you any money to not run
we're all watching you embarrass
yourself yeah I mean you've got you got
a Griff going on that's all you but no
one's coming to your door say hey we'll
pay you to not run that's how much of a
thriving nobody sees her as a threat
Democrats want Cara Lake to be in
politics quite honest let's do it yeah
let's make it easy the vice presidential
candidate and be the United States
Senate candidate do both yeah I mean
is trying to change laws so he can get
in this race which he's not going to get
into you should do the same Carrie you
should do the same but she did I mean
she'll be the first female
Senator Governor VP right I mean
honestly I just gotta say
if we're talking about like really
moving the needle forward for the female
demographic wow you know Kerry Lake she
is a true thought leader oh my God in a
purveyor a fighter of the of the women's
rights to have those three positions as
a [__] liar you know so there was a
few questions that were leveled towards
her that were like how in the [__] is
anyone going to take you seriously on
this this next election if you can't
even stop talking about the [__] last
one right it's been two years dummy yeah
by the time you get to where you're
gonna run for something it's gonna be
damn near four years and you're still
going to be talking about the last one
trying to run for the next one the other
question I think was totally legitimate
and I think a right winger and ask it
and they're worried they're like don't
you think that all this
um election fraud talk is actually going
to suppress our own vote like they're
like this is really worrying that
because there's a lot of people in the
right wing that are saying don't go vote
because it's not worth that that's what
happened in Georgia in the runoff
um Christy here says if the sea fits
Christy on Facebook I think you're
saying
um if the sea fits like Kerry Lake
um is spelled with a c maybe [__] Carrie
[__] I don't know that could be it
speaking of [__]
I'm I'm [__] with a Q [__] with the Q
don't get offended it's just [__] with
a Q okay it's a different kind of
kind of different breed if you want to
tell that this is a Rob Webber too need
someone that was shooting the video
um in the uh in the subway there
um here he is here he is uh
interviewing Captain Q here and this is
like seven minutes long and it goes on
and on Gabe Sanchez this has got three
million views this is it's wild ass [__]
like it's a wild ride and it's worth
watching all seven minutes but we're not
gonna watch the full seven minutes here
because I got some more video I want to
get to
um but let's let's just get a little
taste of what this bonehead believes all
right so we are at a Donald Trump rally
uh why don't you tell me your name and
uh what are you doing here so my name is
Mike I'm from Merrimack New Hampshire
and I'm here to see my favorite
President in the whole world Donald
Trump and why is he your favorite
because he's uh he says he does what he
says he he gets it done you build the
wall I believe he is and I believe the
main but he didn't no no I believe I
believe that's just lies by the
mainstream media and they're covering up
okay so there's gonna be a theme Here
Gabe Sanchez that he needs absolutely
anything anything that is in opposition
to what this guy has been told on online
right on on his uncle Harold's Facebook
page and the Q Anon has pumped through
that Facebook page everything that he
does not vote that he does not want to
believe is a lie told by the media
that's gonna be a theme here I have a
feeling actually I know it because I've
watched this video but let's continue
you win the election absolutely
and why is Indian office
you know what I mean if you know what
this shirt means Q is uh it's a mix of
different things but it's basically
saying that the world is not how it
seems the media is all fake yeah uh the
media is not reporting accurate
information not reporting that he is
actually in office what I believe well
and and what what actually quite a
future of sorters believe is that listen
listen listen up folks listen up the
Nazis believe excuse me excuse me the
Trump supporters believe this are you
listening make sure you're listening
because this is really important here
Trump is still the president right now
he is running a shot of presidency
possibly from Mar-A-Lago the uh White
House the real White House is shut down
you don't like how everything's going
with him in office still so I believe
that it's all a movie We're watching
yeah that's what I it's all a movie
listen I've been saying this for a long
time we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life and there is a
huge Q Anon Superstore on the corner
folks and there is a bunch of dumb
[__] going in there buying I
mean it sounds like they're having a
goddamn clearance sale and everyone's
running in and running out they're
[__] just raiding them oh my God I
mean this guy in the seven minutes he
says some of the dumbest [__] you have
ever heard of in your life he's like not
just me quite a few Trump supporters I
believe this almost all of them almost
we believe that the movie face off
between Nicholas Cage and John Travolta
was actually in early documentary
setting in which Joe Biden is not
actually in office but it's Donald Trump
but Joe Biden isn't actually Joe Biden
and Joe Biden is played by James Woods
it's [__] crazy man he says that [__]
he says James in this clip he says but
the craziest part is he he admits he
admits that he's such a bonehead that he
believes that the whole thing is a movie
and and listen I I could go on and
listen to this at this point I honestly
wish this was a movie because at least
I'd be like oh great credit score we're
done I can go back home all right
exactly but every day I wake up and I go
oh [__] it's a [__] same scene again
God damn it you know it's like an
ongoing Series right right well you you
look at these people and you're like how
how brainwashed you're the most gullible
people I've come to a point where I'm
just like look I can't deprogram all of
you no maybe it's not gonna happen but
it's not gonna happen when the guy goes
what is Q well if you know anything
about this t-shirt like that's the
[__] explanation you give to be like
hey here's a here's a question for you
he's like well you look at this teacher
where we go one we go all that
that's not a new that's not a new no
that's no shut the [__] up so in 2020
right
um during during the covet and during
the George Floyd protest
um this is where Q Anon really started
to grab hold right oh they love those
two drops well and 2020 Q Anon really
grabbed a hold of these people and I was
on the phone with a friend of mine and
this friend of mine um we we used to
like professional wrestling when I was a
teenager right a young teenager like 10
to 14 maybe I was still watching when I
was 16 or 17 and really honestly I like
to go back and watch some of the
nostalgic clips of Hulk Hogan and sting
and some of that some of that wrestling
that happened when I was a kid but I
knew it was fake but here's and by fake
I mean it was scripted it's an
entertainment It's Entertainment now
here's what here's the story here's what
I'll say
this guy looks like this okay look at
the shirt and the hat I mean looks like
a wrestling fan but my friend while I
was on the phone with him he's and he
would watch wrestling like in his adult
life
um every once in a while to try to keep
up with it and he's like you know what
these Trump fans and this Q Anon thing
is it's professional wrestling and I was
like ding ding ding ding ding and that's
where I I coined the idea that we are at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life this bonehead Mike normally wears
like uh Stone Cold Steve Austin shirts
right and he's for the foil right he's
for the bad guy right he's the one who
loves the [__] bad guy he loves the
heel yeah he'll excuse me yeah he loves
the heel he loves the heel he's got the
whoever the heel is he's gonna buy the
t-shirts he's gonna wait for the bad guy
that's what this is that's what this is
they're pretending but it's melted into
real life because they've turned Power
just it's it's one of those things where
it's like oh you've now there's like a
binding that happened between this thing
it's like [__] uh there's like a
symbiosis right they have like there's a
[__] um like if anyone you know watch
or reads like the the you know the Venom
Comics right from from Spider-Man you're
like oh look this alien thing that just
became part of me and I can't really
detach it from myself like I've accepted
that it is me it is part of me uh and
you look at these people who are cute
and they have shirts that say you know
they're they're [__] catchphrase is
where we go one we go all right which is
funny when you've got a group of people
that are saying like we're not cheap
we're not cheap and then you're like
I'm sorry sheep if sheep
together they're moving as one right
they're all moving together in a herd
and you also are moving together in a
herd and you also wear the same thing so
you look the same so you appear the same
so at the end of the day aren't you all
doing the [__] and same thing looking
the same way
I want to push back on you a bit no they
don't all look they don't all look the
same look at look at this cute and honor
here that's the that's the one that he
kissed oh watch this [__] watch this
this is this is you think you think Mike
was wild watch this one look it up right
now 2020 the dumpster fire
oh my God Donald Trump does all the time
I'm gonna grab by the [__] Trump that
[__] all that [__] what's all this
stuff out here
why does he say that you know why he
says that tell me because most of the
so-called women in Hollywood are men
so they in order to find out make sure
they aren't men you gotta grab them by
the [__] but what what
did she um did she say I think she said
she wants to check people's genitalia
the only way to know if there's a vagina
there right is to grab them by the dick
in balls well which again is is sexual
assault yeah they're gender right but
here's the thing here's the thing
Republicans are putting this crazy
bitch's ideas in the policy no they're
they're trying to pass laws they're
trying to pass laws to check children's
genitalia at sporting events that I'm
you think I'm the [__] nut job
everyone's like oh Tony you're going too
far this is ridiculous these are net
jobs these aren't actually Republicans
[__] the [__] the last guy Hammer
his name is Hammer he wants he wants to
make sure that women do not have control
over their bodies in case there's War
Brides okay this woman wants to check
people's genitalia to make sure if
they're male or female that Republicans
are putting these policies into place
what don't you understand what don't you
get where the Republican party's at why
why is it why is it that we have to sit
here and do the whole well Joe Biden's
old and he may be challenged by an
independent with the No Labels oh my God
uh you I'm I'm being forced to vote for
Joe Biden get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense do you know who the threat
is to our democracy do you know who the
threat is to our way of life it is this
[__] crazy ass [__] that Republican
politicians are listening to going hey
you know that's not a bad idea now
grabbing people by the [__] to check
their genitals my comfort isn't
compromised with their genitalia yeah I
I gotta I gotta point something out here
yeah because she she says right and I
don't know he she whatever she goes by
right whatever they go by whatever
pronoun whatever whatever
[__] I might be here I'm not sure what
kind of Maga alien [__] this is going on
but I've seen that person before at
other rallies anyway
this person says uh oh the only way to
know if they're actually men or women or
whatever is to really grab them because
these women in Hollywood are actual men
okay so what she's advocating for is
assault right sexual assault now you
also have to remember that these Q non
Maga people are also the ones who want
to save the children from the Hollywood
pedophiles right so now you've got Maga
people or Republicans
grabbing supposed pedophiles by their
own genitalia
to check if they are the gender that
they say they are
like weird [__] [__] weird right like
it's [__] weird and what makes it
what makes it worse is the fact of what
you brought up which is it's not adults
they're I mean yes they are actually
they are trying to check adults in terms
of what bathrooms you can go in but to
go further they're trying to check
children to say Hey you shouldn't
actually be on this sports team whatever
it might be because your birth
certificate says this and you identify
it well or or someone just wants to
check to make sure what genitalia that
underage yes
man it's weird stuff it's weird stuff
but it's not surprising that Republican
politicians are are doing these real
weird policies because they're listening
to nut jobs like this listen take a
listen
would you grab me by the [__] no but
you probably have one oh hey uh do you
want to find out no no I I'm perfectly
happy not to uh not to look at that oh
wow
I'm Mickey Larson Olson
I'm a 21 year retired Air Force Iraq war
veteran here's the video of her with
Trump
um if you're wondering who this person
is there's there was a hoopla where he
was he was in a pizza joint right and
that what this is yeah yeah he had his
iced Pizza you know Sherry Sherry asked
a good question is she dressed in drag I
have well I mean if if this was in
Tennessee if this was in Tennessee
that'd be a legitimate question you'd
probably want to call the authorities
yeah I'm just saying there's laws in
Tennessee now and you might want to call
the authorities if that's the case
because apparently this person is a
danger to children in Tennessee dressed
like that but here is here is this
person possibly dressed in Dragon we
know okay wait do we know if she
actually was in the military or she
another one of those [__] I I have no
idea I I I can't confirm now she is a
January 6th yeah we know that what was
she went to jail
um
[Music]
Mickey Larson Olson here here it is on
the screen there see there Mickey Larson
Dash got it hyphen Olsen
um but going back to the part of the
tape where it's showing um this person
in this costume uh where the [__] is it
I'm looking for the Trump part because
she's standing she's standing in a
costume next to someone in Trump drag I
don't know if you noticed that in this
pizza place
oh [__]
hang on I gotta restart the [__]
thing
this is ridiculous okay oh 2020 the
dumpster [__] here it is right there
okay so here it is here she is standing
looking at someone in Trump drag you see
that he's got the fake hair he's got
makeup on that's crazy that's a that's a
hell of a trump drag costume let's see
what happens here also January 6th oh he
kissed her he kissed her he didn't grab
her he didn't grab her by the [__] huh
he didn't grab her he must have and
known what her genitalia was maybe I
don't know you're there yeah I was in
jail for January 6. nice what did you do
unlawful entry Capital oh did you break
[__] no I did not I know how it refused
because steal a Podium
supporters didn't do that oh man you'll
find out antifa did it right that's
right oh my god with the antifa she's
like I was there and it was antifa go to
the go to the the clip the link I just
sent you what what is this one so I
looked her up and I found her oh my God
don't tell me
is this a video yeah it's a video
okay this is
the person that's in that drag
it is let's listen uh-huh
15 seconds
it's not very long and it's no hi my
name is Master Sergeant Mickey Larson
Olson I'm over here in Baghdad Iraq I
just like to wish everybody back in
America happy holidays thank you whoa
whoa whoa what kind of wokeish is that
I don't know happy holidays what is she
a Democrat War on Christmas
[__] are you [__] me I'm just saying
are you telling me that she participated
in state state-funded propaganda to kill
Christmas in her uniform are you kidding
me
she's like I want to wish everyone back
home a happy holidays and this is your
government the industrial military
complex that is telling you right now
happy holidays also I just [__]
killed Santa [__] merry Merry [__]
Christmas [__] oh wow that's that's
wild stuff that's wild oh man yeah
anyway so I was skeptical that she was
who she she said she was and she in fact
was a [__] veteran I'll just tell you
this man
um might be another reason that we need
to invest more money in Veteran Affairs
right well our mental health care in
this country I mean
you know that Republicans don't want to
fund those things oh no no they just
wanna they just want to have thoughts
and prayers for it right right have you
seen George Santos going back and forth
with no he was he was he was I was
talking about him earlier because I was
seeing what was trending
um what's the video do you get the video
that is it the one where he's talking to
his constituents is that well there's
one video like that but he's having a
back and forth
um hold on let me see if I can play it
well I mean the one thing that I'll tell
you about George Santos is that
the guy the guy knows how to work his
his lies back into the news I mean it's
incredible
um and you've had a few Communications
with yeah I've actually he finally
blocked me you want to read the text
messages that I that I sent him is this
is the video the one where he's at the
city council and nonsensical not really
impactful jobs dog catcher what what is
this what the [__] is this I don't know
Patriot takes put this out I think it
was in the 30th I am yeah yeah there is
yeah
well GOP apparatus says no you're too
young don't be dog cats so don't be City
Council of town councilman or whatever
nonsensical non-really impacting job you
don't want to do but that's the only
option that they're whoa whoa is he
disparaging city council and dog
catchers I mean he sounds like he's
saying that those aren't real jobs it
feels like he's demeaning dog catchers
right he's like you know what's funny
about that you know what's funny about
him demeaning dog catchers dude the dude
has a dog charity where you stealing
money from people using battling dogs
but we also know that there were dogs
under his care that he lost
so this is this is a real this is a real
real text message that I have with
George Santos okay go ahead here wait I
want to put you in full screen go ahead
I texted him a few times and he finally
responded to one of my texts and it was
on Friday March 24th at 2 44 PM Pacific
I said any comment on accepting to deal
with prosecutors in Brazil after saying
in December 2022 that you did not commit
a crime in Brazil and if you remember on
on March 24th that was a day that CNN
released news that he had in fact agreed
and made a deal with Brazilian
prosecutors he then responded and said
No Deal has been made this news is not
factual and is absolutely contrarian uh
that what my lawyer is telling me not
how you use that word I'd go back to the
drawing board and pick another form of
smearing me now previously he said that
I was smearing him when I brought up the
story about the dogs uh it ends up being
true so then I say in response they say
so just to clarify you stand by your
statement in quotes I am not a criminal
here not here or in Brazil or any
jurisdiction in the world absolutely not
that didn't happen then fast forward to
last Tuesday when it was released by the
Brazilian CNN coverage that he in fact
did uh agree to a deal and that they
have they were finalizing and signing
off and part of the agreement was that
he had to apologize to the victim the
elderly man he stole money from the
checks and also uh had to pay a fine
right so Mr so then I said Mr Santos now
that a settlement has been reached with
your Brazilian prosecutors would you
like to correct your previous statement
or are you still denying any criminal
activity no response had me on red so I
was like [__] and I'm gonna throw
another one out there in case you forgot
your previous statement was I am not a
criminal here blah blah that didn't
happen and since you now agree to
formally confess to the crime and pay
compensation to the victim when and
where will that take place and then he's
like who is this I don't have this
number saved and I go I'm an independent
journalist would you like to comment or
change your previous statement regarding
your criminal activity in Brazil your
statement on 324 2023 yeah you agreed to
a deal with prosecutors you said you
didn't and he goes I don't speak to
unnamed people
so what you're saying is is that George
Santos is still a liar is that what
you're doing still a liar still a liar
still a liar so yeah that was March 24th
and then that was last Tuesday and
whatever that was and uh it's [__]
hilarious because
his ability to to say that it's fake
news it's just a smear campaign even
though it's been confirmed in the press
that he did have this agreement
confirmed by both his own lawyer and
also Brazilian prosecutors and he's like
no no that's a that's a lie oh no no no
no all this stuff that's it's a smear
campaign they're coming after me I'm the
real victim really pulling a trump card
on this one okay this video is [__]
hilarious I made a joke about his uh his
outfit here because well okay well we'll
go through the fashion part of it here
in a second let's listen to the
substance of his lies because it's
George Santos so it's all fun it's all
[__] lies it's it's always alive with
this game Let's listen and and if you're
wondering what the truth is just listen
to him and you'll just think the
opposite be like oh God that's okay
right right let's listen hey guys
Congressman George Santos here hey guys
wanted to clear up that that is funny
let's start it over okay guys hey guys
hey guys hey guys hey guys
foreign
[Laughter]
other people's disinformation he should
probably shut the [__] up considering
the fact that everything everything that
he has ever told anyone anyone I'm
talking [__] anyone even God okay
anything he's ever told anyone has been
a goddamn lie the guy is a walking fraud
who the [__] wait who the [__] is like
you know what I need to know what's
going on in the world let me run to
Jordan Santos's social media so I can
get the truth
who are these [__] are you
kidding me who are the hate guys who is
the hey hey guys hey guys hey guys you
believe my lies what the [__] okay keep
going buddy let's see what the truth is
Bill defunding veteran services
defunding snap supports and Welfare
supports we did no such thing this is
just more disinformation from an
Administration that is struggling to
sell to the American people that the
chaos that is going on in our country is
not their fault stay tuned to more
updates of what's actually going to take
place
hard on behalf of the American people
are under control
um
he's like make sure to stay up to date
so turn on the Bell notification and
make sure to follow me guys subscribe
subscribe for all the lies that like
button hey guys oh my God no for anyone
on YouTube make sure to subscribe and
also hit that like button you're right
don't yeah and also make sure the Bell
notifications on so you don't miss any
of this because we will bring you we
will bring you the George Santos live so
you know exactly what the [__] truth
is oh my God he's like I'll be back
tomorrow from the back of my truck like
also Marjorie Taylor green that was in
the truck with her boyfriend doing an
interview after I got ran out of New
York City after I tried to have an un uh
an un um
George Santos cried Margie Taylor green
was all well they ran they were they
were attacking me
oh my god let's go through the fashion
let's go through the fashion go go ahead
and then we're gonna go oh yeah so so uh
the
one thing I want to bring up here is
George Santos talks about
um the this bill right the the the the
the
uh the build that he's like okay
they're trying what the Republicans are
trying to do is hold the American
economy you want to know you want to
know George Santos has an amendment or
or presented an amendment that was part
of this uh this bill
it was so in in inside of the in this uh
this debt ceiling bill that they had he
proposed and I don't know if it was
actually accepting or I haven't followed
up but as of a week ago it was in this
bill where he wanted to increase the
work requirements in order to get it was
that health care benefits wait so you're
mean he's wanting to take away benefits
from people yeah so so this is what it
translates to he wants to increase the
work requirements from 20 hours to 30
hours so that anyone who's working could
actually so basically he's trying to
make new work requirements even tougher
the guy who lied about almost every job
on his resume in terms of employment is
now trying to make it harder for people
to get benefits by increasing it by 10
hours so if you no longer had to work
the 20-hour part-time hours you now have
to work 30 hours which is 10 hours shy
of the full-time 40 hours so the idea
that that this guy's like oh you know
what I I'm going to make it harder for
everyone else now that I got in this
power this position of power [__] my
constituents and [__] anybody who's ever
trying to make ends meet by working a
job or only able to work 20 hours
because of whatever their conditions or
situation might be [__] them they gotta
work dirty if they want any sort of
benefits anywhere in terms of the
Medicaid work requirements so oh [__]
them you know what is the type of person
that he that's the type of person that
he is he would be the exact recipient of
something like this yeah
we know we didn't make money on Wall
Street he wasn't a [__] Wall Street
whiz kid or anything like that made all
that [__] up damn artist so this is the
guy that would be the direct beneficiary
of that rule right to say like oh it's
20 hours yeah because we're like
Republicans like yeah 20 hours is fine
we're good and George Santos hold my
[__] beer here's 30 hours have you
ever seen the Seinfeld episode where um
George Costanza not George Santos but
George Costanza is trying to keep his
unemployment benefits and he lies to the
unemployment office and tells me I
remember that one vandelay Industries
right
he gives him Jerry's number and he has
to and he has to go and he has to tell
Jerry to make sure to answer his phone
vandelay Industries right right he's
like what do we sell we sell we sell um
uh latex we sell latex I'm a latex sales
I'm your latex salesman so and as the as
the episode ticks on there's one part
where the phone rings and Kramer picks
up the phone and Kramer's like hello and
and he's like Banda who Vanda what Banda
who and George is in the in the bathroom
taking a [__] and he runs out and he's
got to say pants around he's like
vandelay industry Vandal Anderson he
lays on the floor and and of course
Kramer hangs up the phone right and
Jerry walks through the door and sees
George laying on the floor with his
pants down around his ankles and he says
and you want to be my latex salesman
but that is George Santos he works for
vandelay Industries a company that does
not exist and he wants people to have a
worker crime well George Santos I got a
requirement for you I want to have a
truth requirement for your dumb ass in
Congress you said this about his outfit
yeah he said with the number and the
reason the reason I said this to give
everyone context is because he decided
you know he wasn't invited to the White
House correspondent Center boohoo so he
decided to uh
to do a little uh uh
fashion review of people's dresses and
outfits yes that went to it and he says
oh man you think he goes you think that
uh that the racks were all about the
Rack or something yeah they pulled them
out these dresses where else do you get
a dress I'm being serious I don't I mean
if I were if someone's like hey go get a
dress I would go to a dress store I am
just saying like if I need a pair of
cowboy boots I'd go where they sell
cowboy I don't know maybe I'm [__]
off my rocker but I would go to a store
that where they had dresses on the rack
I didn't understand what he was saying I
think he was basically trying to say
that these custom dressers it's not
Designer
I don't know anything about family let
me just I just want to point out
something remember when Michelle Obama
was in office you know where she got her
dresses from where
common places like Target and other
places
what a [__]
where the hell else would you I don't I
don't know I I I buy but I'm just going
to show you you can get you can get
dresses from wherever it doesn't [__]
matter I think I think they have them
you can be a super powerful important
influential person and you get them from
various places right right and places
that that normal people like us can go
to and afford right and that's the whole
[__] point of what's going on but the
fact he's like oh you're not wearing
your Gucci or your Louis Vuitton or your
other one or this is this remember when
they freaked out about aoc's dress
remember when they freaked out here oh
they freaked the [__] out
they freaked out about how sexy AOC
looked in that dress it also looks like
oh nope oh no wait oh I didn't read this
one is that the wrong one that's the
that's interest but when I realized blah
blah yeah um it's the sorry the one that
I meant to say was uh this one J crew
was also a thing so she wore she wore
dresses and again Jay Cruz like you know
it's it's
not too expensive and then a name brand
I know it's a name brand I mean I I buy
like buying up shirts from there I don't
[__] know anything about fashion look
at me black [__] t-shirt I mean I
gotta dude I got a shirt with a [__]
cat and hey oh actually hold on
the cat and then when you pull it down
now that's now that's fashion the middle
finger that's fashion [__] okay well I
gotta get to the fashion review because
we're almost at 2R Jesus Christ we
didn't even get to the correspondence
dinner Clips God we'll get to it
tomorrow yeah I know Nazis and George
Santos what are you gonna do
um with the number of layers George
Santos is wearing you'd think he just
empty the racks at Kohl's and Macy's you
know what maybe he's taking fashion tips
from Steve Bannon I don't know I mean
you know a lot of people they are worse
comments a lot of people in the comments
were saying
they were like all it's missing is three
pens well he Steve Bannon does weirdly
put three of the same exact pin yeah um
in his layers there in his
in his little shirt whichever like the
sixth shirt he puts on he puts the pins
in the stick right right right right
right I wonder if the guy I wonder if
the guy wears a girdle then he puts like
a wife beater on it then he's got a
t-shirt and then he's got another
t-shirt and then he's got to put uh you
know he's got to put a button up a short
sleeve button up and then a long sleeve
button up then a sweater vest a sweater
and then his his jacket and then his
coat like that I mean it's a typical
it's a typical move for anyone who
shoplifts you know where they're like
where the layers right or it's any movie
where you can't tell somebody somebody
um
somebody put in uh Joey from Friends and
where he it's the I know yeah when he
comes in and he's wearing all he's
wearing all of Chandler's clothes yeah
he's even got his underwear on I think
in the gym
listen we're we're throwback here at the
Jordan Michaels podcast Seinfeld
and friends the 90s man when you can
afford stuff well um we're almost out of
time but um did you see uh D Schneider
um did something really stupid this
morning no
um yeah
um what's the game from Kiss over the
weekend that released the statement
um uh um Paul Stanley
and they're they're they're buying up
right wing talking points here and this
is um
this is this is a tough one to swallow
because Dee's not an idiot normally D
Snyder and and really it's the it's the
fear-mongering over uh children and
underage people transitioning in the
parental consent and I keep telling
people this that that the idea of this
um of parents getting their consent
taken away from them yeah because they
never they've had parental rights the
whole time but the problem is the
problem is here is that the right wing
talking points are leaking into the
mainstream and uh D Snyder is uh it's
Paul Stanley who dressed up in makeup
and heels and
um what most people I I mean I thought a
lot of it was could be women's clothing
which I I thought kiss was kind of cool
back in the day D Schneider the same way
a lot of makeup did his hair
um you know
and
um D Snyder uh went all in on the Paul
Stanley kind of bigotry again they're
falling for this under the guys that
that people are forcing children this
Matt Walsh [__] where they're
forcing children to transition and
that's just it's all [__] lies it's
again it's the same as George Santos
lines it's just [__] lines and people
are people in the mainstream are
starting to get a hold of these lines
and it's sad but this is what happened D
Snyder says you know what there was a
time where I felt pretty quote unquote
two I'm glad my parents didn't jump on
the uh to any rash conclusions listen
folks this isn't parents jumping to rash
conclusions here and this is few and far
between there's not there's not that
many cases out there where parents are
going to the point to where it's beyond
felt pretty this is ridiculous D Snyder
is saying he felt pretty and that that
means that somehow
um because and and this is the craziest
part to me because in a few of the
comments and stuff d goes on to attack
some people and say you don't think I
knew I wore makeup I wore this what the
[__] does that got to do with anything
that's ridiculous to say just to say to
I I mean maybe you could use that to
prove a point but to say because I wore
makeup in the 70s and the 80s and I had
my hair enclosed that way and I looked a
certain way back then when I was young
somehow that makes you part of the trans
Community I don't claim to be part of
the trans Community I think I think I
got a lot in common with trans people
I'm a human right I have I have mental
health issues I I have problems of my
own I have uh money problems every once
in a while I mean I I a tough time with
relationships sometimes a lot of people
don't like me a lot a lot of
[__] don't like me but but it
doesn't mean it doesn't mean that I
understand their experience right and
when D Snyder is saying I used to dress
up in costumes and and and and maybe
maybe D Snyder did he felt pretty and
maybe he did it yeah well it's
belittling and it's demeaning on someone
else's experience especially one that
doesn't involve more than just I felt
pretty so I put makeup on there are
people who you know they do drag or they
wear makeup because whatever because
that's what they want to do sometimes
[__] I wear makeup for random things
that I might like I got a little blemish
want to cover that up if I'm going out
right or like on set I wear [__]
makeup on set all the time because
they're like oh we have to have this
makeup for the costume we have to make
sure you look like this or whatever or
hey we just want you to look you know
uh uh you know a clean clean slate we
want you to look natural which you know
if you try to look natural on the camera
without makeup you don't you look worse
than natural right that's just how it is
right but when somebody says you know
like like d Snyder is saying like oh I'm
I'm glad my parents didn't jump to any
conclusions because I felt pretty give
me a [__] break there's a big jump
from the oh I put on some makeup too I'm
gonna now do something that I probably
can't come back from and what's crazy is
that that they're he's equating and
again this is all because the right wing
is doing a damn good job they're doing a
bang-up job folks and this is why you
gotta battle it at every [__] turn
they're doing a bang-up job to make it
seem like every single teenager in this
country is being told by their parents
that you got to be the opposite sex
which is just not even close to the same
universe of the truth it's not even in
the same [__] Galaxy okay and the
idea that D Schneider is saying which uh
again and here's here's what I'll say
about Paul Stanley and D Schneider they
have the right to say this stupid [__]
yeah they have the right to say it and
they can say it doesn't mean they're
wrong it doesn't mean they're correct it
doesn't mean they're operating uh based
in fact and what the actual [__]
truth is they're buying right wing
talking points and I think they're don't
regret this at some point to be quite
honest with you when someone
that is close to them level-headed
enough and on the same level as them
lets them know that hey you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're
really operating in a non-factual type
way when you're saying these things but
D Schneider has the right to say these
things so does Paul Stanley and really
honestly I want this is a good thing for
designer and Paul Stanley's these folks
who who dress like this who put on
makeup for a show who felt pretty what
whatever that whatever you want to call
it this discourse is exactly what we
need we need to have this out in the
mainstream that there is not there is
not parents running around forcing every
single teenager to transition that's the
dumbest [__] thing I've ever heard of
it's it's stupid as [__] and I've heard
a good analogy before and before we
leave
um
is left-handedness
um there was a time in this country
especially there was no left-handed
people yeah there's no left-handed
people and the reason why is because no
one would let you be left-handed you had
to learn how to bat right-handed you had
to learn how to play sports right and
you had to learn how to write
right-handed anything you did all almost
every every single manufacturer when
they were manufacturing toolscape
Sanchez right-handed baby right-handed
and the reason why is because they
didn't want left left-handed just didn't
exist it was just a thing that people
did and you can learn how to you can
learn how to be right-handed okay
now when when we finally acknowledged in
this country that left-handed people
existed and we stopped with the
right-handed [__] guess what
happened guess what happened all of a
sudden the amount of left-handed people
skyrocketed it isn't because there
wasn't left-handed people before that
and all of a sudden everyone wanted to
be left-handed parents are like look my
teenager is going to be hip and you're
gonna be left-handed okay because
there's a there's a left-handed mind
virus out there and I've got it and I'm
Gonna Make You left-handed it's really
stupid [__] the reason why the reason
why people became left-handed is because
there was always left-handed people they
just weren't allowed to be
left-handed Society didn't allow that
and literally people my uncle is
Left-Handed he's he's in construction he
has a lot of left-handed tools and he
has a lot of right-handed tools and the
reason why is because you're when you're
working with him sometimes you pick up
his tool you're like what in the [__] is
this yeah yeah and he would say you know
how I feel now yeah that's how I feel
because and he went to Catholic he went
to Catholic Elementary School Gabe and
and when he was learning how to write
they would whip him on the hand because
he would pick that his he wanted to
write with his left hand [__]
left-handed but they made him learn how
to write right-handed and he can use
he's ambidextrous now as they call it
because he was forced to get his brain
to operate to where he can use both
hands he was forced to do that and again
I I'm not saying that left-handed people
are trans people I'm not saying trans
people is like left-handedness I'm
talking about the societal norm and the
societal Norm now is that we are
accepting a people of whatever
orientation they are whatever gender
what what whatever the [__] you want to
do whoever you want to be you can be
that we will accept you we should accept
you you have the Liberty in this country
to be who you are and we don't we
shouldn't give a [__] we shouldn't care
who you love or or what you are and and
and we shouldn't I mean the big thing is
we shouldn't punish you for being who
you are right we shouldn't punish you
for not doing the thing that we say you
should do and that's what we're seeing
across the states in the U.S they're
passing laws to say hey you can't go
into that bathroom or you can't join
that team or you can't identify as that
thing or whatever it might be because
for them they're like no no the sanctity
of marriage between a man and a woman
you can't be a man if you're a woman you
can't be a woman if you're a man you
can't be something that's non-binary you
can't be any of those things you have to
be this or that right and you and and by
this and that it's by what I what I
determine is this or that right in my in
my Society in my reality in my religious
beliefs you're either going to be this
thing or that thing and there's no in
between right and
um
it's just something that you see
Republicans they they live and they die
by this and no well that's what I'm
going to die by it that's what I'm
trying to make the point here is that
this Republican talking appointing this
Republican bigotry is now leaking into
mines like d Schneider and and this is
this is a turning point and and I'm I'm
actually not saying that this is bad uh
I mean I think it's horrible the way
that D is framing up and Paul Stanley or
framing it up but folks we need to have
this discourse we need to have this
discussion this country is going to have
to realize that as a parent if your
child came to you with this with this
issue that they don't understand their
gender they don't have any idea and
they're just trying to seek help and
they try to go seek help from someone
who who has studied this to figure out
how they can get through this situation
whatever the results may be between the
parent and that child and that child
when they become an adult it's none of
your [__] business it's none of your
business and really honestly if you're
going to take away the right and the
ability of the parents to try to help
their child in life you are a [__]
scumbag so D I know I know I I actually
um I've seen a lot of stuff that these
bows that I follow him
um and and to be quite honest I I don't
I don't think D is a scumbag he's just
being tricked here uh by right wing
talking points they're very effective in
a lot of cases I think it's being
affected on him I'm not sure about Paul
Stanley I really don't know Paul Stanley
that that much but at D's normally a
really uh he's an ally in in the fight
for liberty and D my call is for you to
for this is to go talk go talk to some
parents who have had to help their
children
um either through the transition process
or figure out what what their what their
identity crisis was and go ask them
about the care that they received and go
talk to them because I know Dee's a
compassionate person and I know he would
do that he would go actually Republicans
won't do that D I think would go do that
and he would have the wherewithal to sit
down and have a conversation with
someone and i i i i i d my call is to
you to this and whether he watches this
or not go go talk to some of those
parents because I I don't know if it'll
change your mind but I know you're open
to experience and I know you're open
um to knowing other people's experience
so I'll implore Dee Schneider to do that
everyone
it's been two hours and 10 minutes
already I can't believe that we went
through Nazis Nazis and George Santos
um and we're gonna have plenty more
Nazis tomorrow where that came from I'm
sure of it this is America and we got
the Republican party here in this
country so we're definitely gonna have
some Nazis tomorrow oh one video I
wanted to show you was of the um you
remember the the video of the woman from
um Montana the Republican legislator
where she was telling the story about
her trans daughter and our trans son or
her trans child and she said she would
rather that child commit suicide than
transition you remember that that was a
lie that was a lie and her daughter
actually has made a tick tock so we're
gonna watch that tomorrow okay we're
gonna watch I'm definitely gonna get to
that tomorrow yeah yeah I want to put
that at the top and listen No let me
forget
um to show you that guys that video
tomorrow tomorrow same time same place
serves that [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
y's meal Barn hadass Beacon